-Today is Friday. Happy Friday.
I hope you have a great weekend.
Friday's usually when I catch up
on some personal stuff,
you know,
I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was running a bit behind.
I was running a bit behind
today, so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now,
if that's alright with you guys.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You guys are the best
in the biz.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-That's a still photo.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
Did I tell you my new thing
I'm going to say?
-No.
What's that?
-You know people say,
"Oh, my God"?
-Yeah.
-Or OMG.
-Yeah, OMG, sure.
-I just say, "OM," now.
-Oh.
"Oh, my!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-OM.
-OM!
-Yeah.
-I'm going to start saying,
"He figuratively..."
[ Laughter ]
instead of literally.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
People will go, "He literally
blew my brains out,"
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
No, "he figuratively
blew my brains.
It was crazy," you know?
-OM.
-OM!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Ohm ♪
-♪ Mm ♪
-OM!
-Hello.
[ Laughter ]
Hi!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, the phrase
"I'm doing my own research,"
for being a fancy way of saying,
"I'm checking my aunt's
Facebook wall."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, IHOP's new
Reese's Pieces pancakes.
Looks good, but should we
really be adding candy
to a perfectly healthy pile
of cake, butter, and syrup?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on, overkill.
-Come on.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
seventh inning stretch,
for correctly assuming
I haven't gotten up once
in the last three hours.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-OM.
-Mm!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, pumpkin-flavored
beer coming out once a year,
for being just long enough
for everyone to forget
that pumpkin-flavored beer
tastes terrible.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like, yeah,
that's why we don't --
That's why this doesn't
exist all year.
It's not that good.
-Zucchini-flavored beer.
-Yeah, you only have
zucchini-flavored beer, right?
-Well, yeah, that's all I drink.
I usually do zucchini, eggplant,
-Oh.
-or sometimes beef.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, hay rides,
for making me ask
two questions --
why did we get on this
and when do we get off?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ah-choo!
[ Laughter ]
Hay ride.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Tums,
for being sidewalk chalk
that went to med school.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They like that one.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Frappuccinos,
for answering the question,
"What if a milkshake
could give you a panic attack?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.